as summer approaches
and the prospect of shores beyond
britain the test of holiday hopefuls
will be securing one of these the pcr
proof
agnes and her son needed after an urgent
trip to hungary
the family paid for two tests but they
never arrived
it was like 800 quid around by the end
of the whole thing
um great and those tests
arrived they were recommended by the
government
helpline and these guys didn't send
anything
until day 13 when they randomly sent out
two tests
we're expecting to be able to travel
again from next month if you're going to
a green country most likely to be places
like israel morocco or the maldives
you'll only need one test when you get
back to england
but most of europe is expected to fall
in the amber zone
which will mean quarantining for 10 days
and two pcr tests costing about 100 to
200 pounds
the tests are taken on the 2nd and
eighth day after returning home
a negative result from both and you're
free to stop quarantine
there have been assurances that the
price of tests will fall but hundreds
like agnes have been complaining
about expensive packs and long delays
even with the low passenger numbers
right now
the system is straining if greece opens
up goes on to the green list portugal
one of those big countries and we see
hundreds of thousands
millions of people and asking for these
tests
it's simply not possible that that is
the truth at the moment
the government's list of recommended
tests aren't regulated
and there's limited lab capacity across
the country to process them all
olga ordered tests from a recommended
company too has never arrived
but she was told to stop isolating
anyway it was
on um day two when i got an email here
that i don't
uh after day 10 if nothing hasn't
arrived
i could i'm free to go without any tests
so for me it was shocking because i
thought the idea
is to ensure that we don't bring any new
variants or whatever but it seems to be
it's like a travel text
the governments say they're carefully
monitoring issues raised by the public
and raising every complaint with private
test providers
they say they also monitor providers
performance including their delivery
and test turnaround times they say
they'll take rapid action against any
company that's providing an inadequate
service
but the system is struggling to cope and
the holiday rush
hasn't even begun both heathrow and
other uk airports have turned away
flights in recent weeks because of
congestion in immigration
and if they can't cope at these tiny
volumes how are they going to cope
after may the 17th they need to stand up
get a grip of this
and make sure that we can give a really
warm welcome to all those passengers
coming into the uk
in a few weeks time for those still
clinging to hope
of beaches further afield an
announcement on travel is expected on
the 17th of may
that will be the real test ali forskou
sky news